c'est la playstation 5
La taille est de 104 mm de largeur et 300 mm de hauteur et 260 mm dans le pays.
En lui faisant une taille plus grande que ps 4
Performances considérablement améliorées en termes de puissance de traitement et de silence
La face avant a un port USB de type C et compatible USB Love Speed
port 5a
Aucun côté n'a 2 ports de type A pour USB super rapide
port LAN
rapport 1 an
Équipé d'une borne de puissance
Le février sur la face avant est l'orifice d'admission
Par exemple, tout sera jeté
retirer le socle
Ka
Lors de la réception d'une paire, elle est fixée avec une vis à monnaie
Les joints enlevés sont placés dans le stand pour se venger.
Hmm
cet invité
prêt
Faites pivoter la base pour une plus grande
Veuillez insérer la base selon cette marque
Les panneaux blancs des deux côtés peuvent être retirés par le client pour le moment.
soulever le coin arrière
Je ne le regrette pas quand je glisse
Ah
Soulevez également le fond blanc
je vais le mettre chaud
Hmm
On dit qu'il n'y a pas de ventilateur pour refroidir ici
respirer l'air du soleil
si ps 5
à 3 endroits
Installé un attrape-poussière
La poussière accumulée sur Last Gen-chan peut être aspirée avec un aspirateur à travers ces trois trous.
un m
Pour le stockage d'extension future
Contrôler l'augmentation des chirurgies longtemps après la prise en charge de pcie 4.0
Je vais démonter la PlayStation 5 d'ici
rouge 6
va
soulever plus
e
Diamètre 120mm Epaisseur 45mm
Contrôle 9 grands ventilateurs de refroidissement
enlever le visage
Pouah
Quatre
p euh
unité de lecteur blu ray hd goodra
L'unité sous tension est entièrement logée dans un boîtier en tôle
De plus, en montant avec 20 isolateurs, le bruit de conduite et l'anxiété à 0 heures 5 fois sont réduits.
laissez-moi définir
Retirez les câbles menant au Wi-Fi 6 et à la stabilité de la cabine 5.1
retirer la plaque de protection
ps 2
Le processeur est Achiko avec 16 threads et fonctionne jusqu'à 3,5 GHz
Le GPU fonctionne jusqu'à 2,23 GHz
Atteindre 10,3 téraflops
La mémoire est équipée de gddr 6 à 8
Pandharb est jusqu'à 448 Go/s
Stockage transformé en 1 bd avec 825 Go ss beauty à bord
Exécution
Singer est un contrôleur ssb donc la vitesse de lecture est le taux de transfert de données brutes par seconde
5,5 Go accélère et réduit considérablement les temps de chargement du jeu
le soc d'ester exécute un petit grand à une horloge très élevée
Pour cette raison, il n'est pas très coûteux de faire une autre erreur dans la puce en silicium, elle est donc prise en sandwich entre les dissipateurs thermiques en feuille.
Il était nécessaire d'améliorer considérablement les performances du matériau conducteur de chaleur dont on dit qu'il fonctionne.
La PS 5 adopte du métal liquide pour cet appareil afin d'obtenir des performances de refroidissement stables et élevées sur le long terme.
a été
Depuis plus de deux ans, nous nous préparons à recruter ce ministre de haut rang.
Nous avons effectué toutes sortes de tests auxquels nous pouvons penser et avons atteint l'adoption.
Voici le Healsink pour le fichier ps
J'utilise des touches et des tuyaux pour jouer sur PS 3 et PS 4
En concevant la forme et le flux d'air, nous avons atteint les performances du saut de papier et du toto.
rizière
C'est le pingouin littéral qu'il a prévu
hein
Voici tous les membres de Playstation Files
station de jeu